so as we told you we sat down yesterday
with Russell Brand the comedian actor
and now
frankly kind of a public intellectual
for about an hour and a half on our show
Tucker Carlson today we want to share
more of it tonight in particular brand
spent a lot of time thinking about and
telling us about the covid lockdowns and
the point of them was maybe the clearest
explanation we have heard of what we've
just lived through here it is
[Music]
I think kovid provided a lens through
which we could scrutinize the Machinery
of power and how the intentions and
agenda of Power are able to play out
coalesce and let's call it conspire when
a crisis occurs how a tendency a
globalist tendency to increase
surveillance a big Tech appetite to
capture data and a comparable appetite
within government converges the Great
American comedian George Carlin used to
say there is no need for conspiracy
where interests converge it seems that
even if at its Advent it was a
legitimate crisis and I certainly
wouldn't make any contention around that
it was opportunistically handled in
order to enhance regulation and control
at a time where regulation and control
are increasingly difficult to implement
as people are more suspicious of
institutional power so in a sense the
best way to understand covid I believe
is to take covid out of it and look at
how the institutions both corporate and
government behaved around it how did
they benefit how did they utilize it
what narratives did they disseminate and
which narratives did they control and
curtail even with the recent text
messages from our health minister at
that time Matt Hancock you can
explicitly see it was exploited oh no we
need to scare people is there any way
high net worth individuals can get into
the country all these conversations but
many people that are cynical about the
behavior of the powerful believed were
happening were indeed happening the way
that natural immunity was discussed
proved to be true I.E their natural
immunity is effective they probably
understood earlier than they admitted
their natural immunity was effective and
for reasons that well what what could it
be and what could be the reason that a
monetizable solution to kovid was
prioritized over a non-madetizable is
there anyone involved in the situation
that has a profit motive let's look at
the data and like you know so what it
was just revelatory like the apocalypse
always will be the apoc apocalypse's
revelation of all what was always there
corruption convergence of interests
alliances this is not conspiratorial
this is the moot recital of economic
interests and the ordinary movements of
the powerful if people can uh honor one
another and talk to one another in good
faith and recognize that anybody if
they're like there's a whole debate
between like that I've sort of felt a
little bit around me even for coming
here I feel like it used to just be
normal that someone in your family would
be a conservative and someone in your
family would be liberal and someone in
your family would be socialist and
someone in your family would be trans
and someone in your family would be gay
and different races are coming together
is this part of who we are and if it
isn't the part of who we are it's
certainly part of who we need to become
and it's something that we need to
deeply deeply encourage uh immediately
in the moment now and you think that can
be done it's the only option and
therefore it cannot be discussed it must
be implemented because the alternative
we can see from the tendency towards
geopolitical disaster a set of
centralized as interests you seem to
unconsciously be directing us towards
nuclear Armageddon if not with Russia
than with China they have to be
interrupted it simply has to it simply
has happened there is no choice and in a
situation where there's no choice human
Ingenuity and Al Collegiate Spirit must
take over we have no option but to find
it in ourselves to forgive one another
to move forwards to love one another
values that may seem a little hokey and
old-fashioned because they pertain to
things that are ineffable and difficult
to describe but are vital and that we
all understand
you
well that was pretty intense uh
definitely worth listening to you can
stream part one of our conversation
right now part two comes out 7 A.M on
Fox Nation
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight